delivered to you the people of America
the situation in Iraq and Syria's
disaster but there is one happy fact
about the scenario Isis is stalled and
in Iraq it's actually losing ground if
these trends continue Isis will be
unable to hold on to territory in Iraq
and in the foreseeable future
when Isis swept northern Iraq in June
2014
they looked unstoppable that's how these
victories possible these victories come
only from allah azza wa jal and that is
how with these small numbers of soldiers
that we have we take these massive
victories but their weaknesses began to
be exposed starting as early as August
2014 when Isis made a boneheaded mistake
it invaded iraki Kurdistan and
threatened Erbil the Iraqi Kurdish
capital we will not stop fighting we
will not put down our weapons until we
reach your lands but your schmurder
defended themselves and then turn the
tables on Isis and began offensive
maneuvers which seriously crimped Isis a
style in northern Iraq bring every
nation that you wish to us bring every
nation that you want to come and fight
us it means nothing to us müber there
were Americans in Erbil and the United
States was not going to allow Isis to
pose a serious threat to its own
citizens so in August the United States
began bombing Isis positions to protect
Kurdish Holdings and to protect the Azia
menorah in Iraq who Isis had threatened
to exterminate and to the leaders to
Obama the tourney ever I say this these
weapons that we have these soldiers we
will not stop fighting we will not put
down our weapons the Iraqi army that was
swept over in June was weak disorganized
and full of people who fled from the
first sighted battle it's smaller now
but it has shown battlefield
capabilities particularly the Special
Forces in combat with Isis its
buttressed by an enormous amount of Shia
militias these militias together with
the Iraqi army are much more disciplined
and much more effective than the
scattered weak Iraqi army in June 2014
was and now that Isis is facing a
serious foe that's adapted itself to
tactics they're no longer as capable of
taking anyone by surprise the US
airstrikes since August and September
have been more effective than most
observers suggested the reason that's
true is Isis's obsession with territory
it wants to openly defend territory and
that means putting their troops out in
ways that make them vulnerable to
airpower in conventional battles
that's why US airstrikes have been so
effective at disrupting resistance bring
your planes bring everything you want to
us because it will not harm us why
because we have Allah so again and this
is something that you do not have to say
Isis is losing isn't to say that Isis is
going to disintegrate sometime in the
next year or so this may take a while
and moreover the group may somehow
reconstitute itself as an insurgent
group or terrorist group after it loses
control of territory the fact that Isis
is losing refers to the fact that it is
increasingly incapable of holding on to
territory which is its key mission right
now as the Islamic state
[Music]